the women of the view
were just debating the supreme court
nomination
and joy behar and whoopi goldberg
went on some discourse gave some lecture
on the law and the courts that was very
nearly incomprehensible
you know
that somebody like amy coney barrett uh
was put in there
because she's a white woman yeah who
they say well she'll go against abortion
rights and she's a woman so that was
deliberate i think clarence thomas a a
black guy a black man a justice okay
i'll give it to him he's a smart guy but
he is to the right of attila the han
this guy and they put him in there
thinking oh a black man will go against
voting rights which is what he does and
it was a terrible and it's a very tricky
business they're pulling over there when
you think about it not to mention the
fact that mitch mcconnell has no concept
of the law when it comes to the supreme
court they know the law they're not
following it right they don't want to
follow now and he's allowed to not
follow terribly disrespectful to appoint
someone like clarence thomas with his
philosophies to the seat of thurgood
marshall civil rights
can anybody tell me what these hens are
clucking about
what on earth are any of these people
talking about
mitch mcconnell he doesn't know anything
about the law yeah mitch mcconnell who's
been in the senate since 1831 one of the
most adept parliamentary geniuses in the
history of the us congress he doesn't
know anything about the law and whoopi
goldberg realizes that what joy behar
said doesn't make any sense and so she
says something to contradict that but
that also doesn't make any sense namely
that they know the law they're just not
following the law what what law are they
not following
they have no answer it's just this vague
sort of insinuation
clair amy coney barrow was put in that
position she's a woman but she was put
in that position to vote against roe
versus wade
and clarence thomas he's a black guy
okay i'll give it to him
joy bayer says okay i'll grant he's a
black guy
thank you joy thank you for for uh
giving clarence thomas his race that's
that's very kind of you
yo cal granny's a black guy sure he's
smart enough but he's bad he's got a bad
judicial philosophy i joy behar who does
not have one 100th the iq of clarence
thomas i am i who have never studied
anything about constitutional law i am
going to pontificate
about what adult clarence thomas is
one of the most accomplished jurists in
the history of the court
he does he's voting against voting
rights
what does that what does that mean
and then the other one i don't even know
her name but the other one on the view
she says yeah and his wife and the
insurrection and the whoopi says that's
a whole show what are you people talking
about you have no idea what you're
talking about
it's just clock i don't like this
this is there's a lesson here for
conservatives not merely that if you
want to preserve your your brain cells
you don't tune into this show a show
hosted by five women and four brain
cells it's that's not just the lesson
the lesson is
it is a losing game for conservatives to
play identity politics
it's a losing game we think sometimes we
conservatives we try to get really
clever we say
if we play the game and we
nominate a
i don't know racial minority woman
of a minority religion of this then but
then that person does what we want them
to do
oh that'll that'll own the libs yes
that'll convince them that'll prove to
them we're not racist they don't care
what they're insinuating here is that
amy coney barrett isn't really a woman
that clarence thomas isn't really a
black guy sure they might look like a
woman and a black guy but really because
of their beliefs they're not and so and
actually republicans are even more
racist even more sexist for choosing a
woman and a black eye just tune it out
just to go with the best people go with
the best people okay clarence thomas is
not a great jurist because he's a black
guy he's a great jurist because he's
clarence thomas i am giving you money
you're welcome how do you get the money
you download the free get upside app you
use the promo code knowles and then
whenever you go to the gas pump you will
get 25 cents per gallon cash back
except
on your first fill up
then you will get 50 cents per gallon
cash back that's a lot of money people
who are driving a lot are making up to
200 to 300 a year cash back
i'm just handing you 200 to 300 you want
it yes or no you want to take it i would
especially now with gas prices going
through the roof there is no catch there
is only cash back you get the cash back
straight to your bank account or if you
prefer through paypal or amazon or an
e-gift card to some other shop
super easy just download the free get
upside app right now use promo code
knowles canada les to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your first tank
that is code nulls i'm so glad you found
this video because i have been told by a
number of you out there that even though
you have rung the bell and subscribed to
this channel you're not getting
notifications when the new videos come
out isn't that's kind of strange i don't
i wonder why
why that might be youtube so if you want
to get notifications and the full
uncensored show for free head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe leave a five-star
review to the michael knowles show we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you